[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
so sollte die stadt für alle gebaut
barrierefrei wie vor dem kellertheater
seite gallen der schriftsteller
christoph keller kämpft mit unverblümten
war um für gleichstellung
[Musik]
wir kommen nach dem kulturplatz ich bin
heute in st gallen auf dem weg zum
schriftsteller christoph keller jeder
krückel ein superheld dass der titel
seines neuesten buches ein
schonungsloser bericht über das
alltagsleben mit behinderung christoph
keller sagt er sei nicht behindert
sondern er werde behindert
und zwar von uns allen was das bedeutet
das möchte ich herausfinden
christoph kraller wiegen zusammen und
redet über das neue buch von ihnen als
ich ein provokanter titel grad opel
super held wird man nur so gehört
provokation ist man dass man das war die
nacht und darum eine denkt die zwölfte
titel und ja dann ist es eine
provokation und den wert besser gehört
mehr brauche das wird immer noch viel zu
viel
das war vor etwa haupt einfach hinter
dem russischen regisseur wurde das war
seine art ist geschichte und merken wir
gott darum mir das wort zeigen dass sie
da die waffe am anderen aus der hand
nimmt
und dazu minderen eigene ziemlich
eigenen schutzschild macht und oft yard
run in die werre im moment genau deshalb
bestehe ich durch das aber das ist der
schublade wie der andere als platte wo
es ja gar nicht hingehört so optischen
tricks cs ist auch schluss klären
es ist es gartenfreund ästhetisch der
krippe lufthansa sieht superheld die
denken ich beides nicht obwohl um als
mensch mit behinderung noch intakt
orange und sobald sie das jetzt gibt es
probieren weil ich habe mit ihnen
mithalten können links geht es unseren
schicksal ist christoph keller ein
offenes buch
[Musik]
der autor zahlreicher romane essays
theaterstücke bringt aktuell intimes zu
papier in form einer collage aus
gedanken gedichte erzählungen erinnerung
zum beispiel an die diagnose spinale
muskelatrophie im teenager alter
je länger je mehr verliert keller seine
muskelkraft gehen stehen seit jahren und
denkbar schreiben eine art therapie eine
leidenschaft älter als der befund der
unheilbaren krankheit
sie sagen wir favorit ich krieg dich
sogar lebensfreude dieser srg maria
crange schriebe bevor er war hatte könne
lasse jetzt möglich wie es nicht stimmt
aber das spielt keine rolle
seine kindheit ein heikles kapitel die
beiden älteren brüder ebenfalls an
spinaler muskelatrophie erkrankt sein
vater dem er die liebe zur kunst
verdankt sucht trost und vergessen
im alkohol
es hatte ihn zu einem fluchenden grobian
gemacht bei einem grenzwertigen brutal
und weichling entweder hätte rück
bekannt oder durch die anderen sind auch
eine mini sehen sie oder hat aktuell
kindergarten in basel da auch in
jüngerer vergangenheit trifft das
unsagbare k wort wie ein messerstich und
stirbt krippe stellt brüllt ein weißer
von der anderen straßenseite herüber
geschehen in new york wo keller den
großteil der letzten 20 jahre lebte der
liebe wegen
mitte der 1990 er jahre lernte er seine
frau die lyrikerin jen heller levy
kennen sie lernt verstehen was exklusion
bedeutet
[Musik]
wenn andere und sehen sehen sie uns aber
es gibt viele die sich dafür entscheiden
uns nicht wirklich zu sehen ihn noch zu
sehen
wahrgenommen mitgedacht werden
dafür setzt sich keller vehement ein
egal buch
in new york fotografiert er kaputte
trottoir ränder will damit die behörden
unter druck setzen doch dann erkennt er
die schönheit in den bildern
ein paar sind nun teilen des neuen buchs
mittlerweile lebt das paar ganzen der
schweiz wegen des fliegens für keller
die reinste tortur und wegen amerikas
präsident keller nennt ihn im buch nicht
beim namen positioniert sich aber klar
und wortgewaltig der aggressive
ausbeuterischen betrügerische blöde böse
ja immerhin zins wird historische
pflaster worden das war er als 80 jahren
das ist ja das ist die massage jemand
was wir nicht zurück und wie ist das
eigentlich dass ich nebenher laufen
größten mit westerwelle war aber laufen
ist das okay ja ich jetzt aber sehe wenn
sie denn sagen dass wir gott bringen
oder so denn alles wenn sich auf die
behörden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also das ist jetzt nur dass ich jetzt
noch anspruchsvolle um sichtbarkeit
jetzt dass das auto gesehen was sie
machen ja was ist jetzt noch relativ ist
kontrollschwelle sind kein problem
nein also eben dort wo es wiederum nicht
übertrieben oder sieht man halbe jahr
beim areal in eine andere realität die
der korona realität was bedeutet das für
sie negativ sexy während der korona
zieht weil eigentlich während menschen
mit der behinderung
während lucy war grossartig
konsolidieren
mehr wisse bereits wenig wie es innere
größte formfaktor anteile so ein
herrgott und hätte da ja und man aber
tatsächlich passiert ist ist das war
eigentlich der explosion noch
ausgeschlossen worden sind
dass ein bieter gefunden
mit reden gehört werden von behörden und
von städteplanern ein zentrales anliegen
von christoph keller aber unsere städte
müssen sich jetzt sowieso wandeln
wie wollen wir in zukunft städtebau und
damit sie für uns alle lebenswert sind
und wie wollen wir sie konzipieren damit
wir auch den nächsten lockdown gut
überstehen über diesen fragen brüten
architektinnen und städteplaner klar ist
corona spielt auch in diesen fragen eine
immense rolle
erinnern sie sich noch an diese bilder
die plötzliche ruhe die städte kamen
durch corona zum stillstand
rund um den globus
und heute
wird corona das gesicht unserer städte
verändern wie werden wir in zukunft
wohnen und arbeiten und sind diese
veränderungen von dauer
das ist natürlich hätte der maus einig
sie dass man dass man immer einfach wird
zum zum vorhergehenden status meint der
architekturtheoretiker sascha rösler den
wir im home-office antreffen
gerade das home-office läutet einen
wandel ein der unsere städte prägen wird
firmen wie die novartis bieten auf
wunsch ihrer mitarbeiter home office für
immer an
ein drittel der büros auf dem prestige
reichen novartis campus wird in zukunft
nicht mehr gebraucht werden
man hat eine riesige büroflächen au zum
anbieter und tragisch wenn man das kann
dann neu entwickelter und neu gestaltet
ideen für neue arbeitswelten haben
konjunktur
die korona krise als chance hier scheint
das zuzutreffen
gruner wissen katalysator gestarteten
beschleunigt oder sind sagt matthias
weber der für die beratungsfirma wirst
partner den immobilienmarkt analysiert
nehmen nun die büroflächen wegen corona
und home office ab wird partner hat er
zu 500 unternehmen befragt
wir sind überzeugt dass der vielleicht
aber darauf als solches nicht wert sinke
durch home office sondern das dreschen
anders werden denn ein corona
servicebüro wie es etwa die möbel design
firma vitra vorschlägt braucht mehr raum
für wenige arbeitsplätze büros wird es
also weiterhin geben trotz home office
sie sehen einfach anders aus großzügiger
luftiger mit vielen begegnungszonen es
wäre in zukunft neue bereiche nötig sie
sogenannte bürolandschaft geheimnis des
nennen wo kommunikation wichtig ist der
austausch unserer mitarbeitenden zeigt
dass der soziale austausch oder der
wissenstransfer vom büro der zukunft ins
quartier der zukunft unterwegs mit
kathrin kegler direktorin des amts für
städtebau in zürich hier in zürich
albisrieden wird heute schon so gebaut
dass man für die nächste pandemie
gerüstet ist
[Musik]
so heißt dieser coworking space
gegründet von vier berufstätigen müttern
eine kinderkrippe gehört dazu denn kurze
wege zwischen familie und arbeit sind
zentral erst recht in zeiten der
pandemie wenn man möglichst wenig
unterwegs sein sollte
es ist es wo danke ich dem zusammenhang
auch den nerv der zeit trifft und wo
vielleicht sind auch unter dem aspekt
von einer pandemie wo man die erfahrung
gemacht und mit homeoffice dass man zeit
hat
daher danke möglichkeit flexibler
reagieren auf so verrannt und die
bedürfnisse carola hat gezeigt plötzlich
braucht es zu hause oder im coworking
space mehr arbeitsfläche da helfen
flexible räume wie hier fünf meter hoch
sind sie je nach belegung lassen sich
neue etagen einziehen
auch wichtig bei einer pandemie
gemeinschaft eine ab verbindet die
mietparteien in diesem geschäftshaus zur
community das motto dass das im
bewegungsraum krank sind
die der krise wichtigkeit von
attraktiver und erreichbare freie ring
freiräume gleich ums eck alles was man
braucht findet man im quartier wie
wichtig das sein kann hat uns die
pandemie gelehrt denn wenn stadtteile
mono funktional gebaut sind bricht bei
einer krise alles zusammen
im londoner finanzdistrikt bleiben seit
corona tausende von bankangestellten zu
hause als folge verödet die city noch
mehr und restaurants müssen schließen
solche szenarien sollen in basel
verhindert werden
für das knie beck areal ein riesiges
entwicklungsgebiet entsteht ein
bebauungsplan dass eine mögliche nächste
pandemie mit berücksichtigt vor ort
treffen wir lukas ott den leiter der
stadtentwicklung basel sich sicher sehr
speziell das sind riesig hektar im
zentrum von randstad basel ist natürlich
eine wunderbare ressourcenschutz stadt
entwickelt das klybeck areal war bis
anhin eine art verbotene stadt 30
hektaren anlagen der chemischen
industrie abgeschirmt hinter mauern
jetzt liegen sie brach es gibt viele
pläne vorerst auf dem reißbrett
aus imposanten fabrikationshallen werden
vielleicht ateliers aus der ehemaligen
personal kantine eine quartier beitz
und seit corona wird auf eines besonders
geachtet viele grün für den aufenthalt
im freien soll es geben
schon realisiert ist die umnutzung
dieses bürogebäudes früher gingen hier
angestellte der ciba geigy ein und aus
heute ist es ein mix von ateliers und
wohnungen
die größten sind so genannte co living
wohnungen hier eine musterwohnung
fünf meter teilen sich eine wohnung mit
großen gemeinschaftsfläche
[Musik]
10.000 menschen werden dereinst auf den
fleck areal wohnen ebenso viele hier
arbeiten ein quartier für fußgänger wäre
das ziel eines das krisen die korona
wirtschaftlich und sozial gewachsen ist
das alles soll im gleichen stadtteil in
briefen quartier keine stattfinden also
das ist stadt vor der kurzen wir jede
medien jever suchen und setzte corona
wird die form des arbeitens und des
zusammenlebens verändern und damit das
gesicht unserer städte das ist auch gut
so denn das nächste virus kommt bestimmt
[Musik]
inoffiziell
aber so daher wird der comedia burhan
liegt also in suzuka sie
[Musik]
danke
das thema der letzten station für die
heutige tag in der lieblingsbar von
christoph konzentriert ist und jetzt
gefahren ist eben ein buch legacy als
positives beispiel trumps sofort pro
aktie also manchmal streetworker damit
konfrontiere mehr ganz mit ihm auch
darum aufmerksamkeit staatslenker dass
man an dem niemand gedanken aus farbiger
sondern probierte bis zu ende aber die
idee stecke jetzt jede stufe steht im
prinzip für ihre strukturelle
diskriminierung weil es einfach nur
darum gehen defizit dass ein treffen
diene oder das haus mit ihnen aber da
bietet mit dem houssine kharja schaffen
werte dienen kein job und so vorstellt
und alle die stufe multipliziert
der strukturelle diskriminierung wo es
in sich hat die ware hindernis oder die
schlimmste das eigentlich jetzt mal los
- sind aber matschiner die sichtbare es
sind ganz einfach die unsichtbare es ist
das paradox vom behinderte sie dass wir
einerseits straße wahnsinnig sichtbar
ist auf der anders sieht denn die ist es
grundfalsch verwenden wenn die super
kraft für ein superheld wird kraft
völlig unsichtbar sie da gibt's lineal
taxis spiel wir wenn ihr mit meiner
kreditkarte zahlen über die kreditkarte
aber person hinter der kasse gibt sie im
inneren frau zog
vielleicht weil sie stehen daneben ist
oder wo maria aparecida es ist einfach
anfangen sichtbarkeit und das ist ein
alltags diskriminierungs ganze leben
zählt renommierte alemannischen
literaturpreis gewonnen was bedeutet das
in bezug auf sichtbar sie sichtbar
werden
als schriftsteller bedeutet mir sehr
viel und tollen internationale preis
aber sie bietet eine ganz ganz ganz ganz
wenige schriftsteller im rollstuhl
wo überhaupt nach ständiger preis über
hundt und der vg werke
krawall etat aber hat es gibt es soviel
ort von elena kann und in den ni klatten
wer die einfach ihr hobby jahre
systematisch ausgeschlossen während und
das resultat ist ein einfach weniger
relative weniger literaturfestivals im
bereich weniger brise weniger
verkaufszahlen unter und einen
rattenschwanz danke für die begegnung
hätte gesagt nicht danke wir machen
jetzt einen harten szenenwechsel und
schauen für einen moment vom st gallen
nach beirut die schweren hafen
explosionen dort von anfang august haben
auch das kulturleben schwerstens
erschüttert da war es gerade die kultur
in beirut ein überlebens elixier eine
reportage kabelkanal hatte glück als in
beirut der hafen explodierte war er
gerade in der schweiz
jetzt besuchte in genf aufgewachsene
libanesische kulturschaffende eine
benefizveranstaltung in fribourg
[Musik]
eine gruppe von exil libanesen will
ihrem land helfen
mit humus und musik die heimat kann das
gut gebrauchen
[Musik]
wer im libanon lebt ist inzwischen
völlig verstört schon vor der explosion
als ich noch dort war drehten sich alle
gespräche und dieselben vier dinge wie
viel ist unser geld gerade wert was
kosten die grundnahrungsmittel gibt es
bald krieg und wie komme ich bloß aus
diesem land raus so etwas wirkt sich
natürlich auch auf die kulturszene aus
in beirut herrscht endzeitstimmung schon
vor der explosion setzten corona und
eine schwere wirtschaftskrise der stadt
zu
nabil leitet hier das kulturzentrum
station beruht vor einem halben jahr
probten schweizer und libanesen noch
gemeinsam für ein projekt des zürcher
neumarkt theaters dann ging es bergab
erst kann corona danach die
wirtschaftskrise
[Musik]
nun ist die station zu und in der
ramponierten halle lagern hilfsgüter
auch die kunstschaffenden sind im krisen
modus sowie die fotografen miriam bonus
ursprünglich war sie beim projekt des
neumarkt theaters dabei jetzt
dokumentiert sie ihre heimatstadt
dieses jahr ist das schlimmste seit
langem
aber all die probleme und
schwierigkeiten bedeuten eben auch dass
es umso wichtiger ist alles zu
dokumentieren und weiterzumachen mit dem
was man als künstler am besten kann
ich suche mir nicht mehr aus was ich
fotografiere die dinge drängen sich mehr
auf und ich mache das aus notwendigkeit
und nicht etwa weil ich es mir
ausgesucht habe polos fotos haben es bis
ins berühmte timer gesehen geschafft sie
zeigen die opfer der explosion aber auch
die wut der menschen über die korruption
und die unfähigkeit der regierung
beirut kulturszene war letztes jahr bei
den protesten an vorderster front mit
dabei
doch spätestens seit der explosion sind
die kulturschaffenden zermürbt
[Musik]
denn institutionen wie das usoc museum
das wichtigste kunstmuseum der stadt
sind völlig zerstört auf staatliche
hilfe wartet seiner arena die direktorin
bis heute vergebens
[Musik]
hier hängt alles von der
zivilgesellschaft ab nicht nur im
kulturbereich auch im sozialen wohl
angst unzählige angeles die arbeit des
staates übernehmen
der staat hat uns aber nicht nur im
stich gelassen er hat auch all das
zerstört das wir in den letzten jahren
aufgebaut haben und genau das ist es was
uns so wütend macht im museum beseitigen
deshalb freiwillige die schäden aber wie
lange noch immer mehr junge libanesen
haben genug und wollen weg für die
kulturstadt beruht ist das eine
katastrophe
übrig bleiben die ruinen einer
glorreichen vergangenheit
von der explosion zerstörte
kulturdenkmäler aus osmanischer zeit wie
dieser stadt balle der familie zog
für rostock liegt ein stück von beirut
seele in trümmern
[Musik]
das ist dramatisch denn das historische
und architektonische erbe der stadt
wurde in einer sekunde ausgelöscht ich
hoffe dass einiges gerettet werden kann
aber leider gibt es im libanon kein
gesetz dass dieses kulturerbes schützt
das den besitzern solcher häuser hilft
auch die libanesen in der schweiz wollen
helfen nabil fliegt demnächst zurück in
die heimat um die kulturszene dort zu
unterstützen
zurück in ein land mit 18
religionsgemeinschaften
das führt zu konflikten ist aber auch
seine stärke und genau darauf setzt
nabil
dieses land ist enorm wichtig denn es
zeigt dass ethnische kulturelle und
religiöse vielfalt möglich ist
gerade auch im nahen osten und das auch
noch in einem mehrsprachigen umfeld
dieses land ist ein symbol
genau das macht es so bedeutend
zwar bekommt der libanon jetzt hilfe vom
ausland
doch als letzte woche im hafen von
beirut erneut ein großbrand ausbricht
zeigt sich dem land steht ein langer weg
bevor
[Musik]
ja das war unser kulturplatz aus st
gallen wo wir auch den blick in krisen
gewinn zu erwarten und solche können in
peru seien genauso auch wie auf dem st
galler kopfsteinpflaster zum schluss
richten wir den blick auf erika stucki
endlich große ehre für diese große
musikerin
das habe ich mir gedacht dass sie diesen
sommer mit dem grandprix musik
ausgezeichnet wurde
nun haben wir diese neue königin der
neuen volksmusik treffen können und
verabschieden uns für heute mit dieser
begegnung bevor wir uns hoffentlich
nächste woche wieder sehen auch mit viel
musik dann bei der geschwister pfister
in bern
[Musik]
an der queen geadelt mit 100000 franken
und für den schweizer musikpreis
juli liebt sie wie den rock'n roll
geboren in san francisco saugt sie den
sound der hippies auf
wenn die mitleid zeppelin fox ist die
anderen stammen mit indischer musik
spielen sicher das hat nicht fest
[Musik]
mit achteinhalb jahren der umzug ins
oberwallis in die heimat des vaters von
der brodelnde metropole in die streng
katholische walliser provinz ein
alptraum
musikalisch ging sie ihren eigenen weg
sie kann es mit blechbläsern und sogar
mit mariachi
[Musik]
diese große vielfalt wird nun belohnt
mit dem schweizer gruppe musik acht
monate richtig einmal gehört im moment
als ich im januar consult magic 8 jetzt
an der opera sander und labors und
natürlichen dezember in amerika stuckis
vor josef ruf schon bald wieder auf den
bühnen so corona will
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos